we are trying to take devon's power for
the cryogod
i fear this might fall short of their
true intentions
i think they intend to use barbados
connection to the wind to draw him out
just like lisa traced the source of the
storm
the god of animal hasn't been seen for
more than a thousand years
what makes you think that's their
intention
uh huh
forget it i don't like having to pry
here take this
what is it at the skies to protect your
identity
put it on before you run into the future
so
huh
[Music]
uh
ah no no the entire floors defenses
have been broken how did you guys know
that the place is being kept is locked
up tight
i don't know which one of the guards has
it this guy looks like he's a
huge one of the 11 singular when she
gets her hands on you she's going to
string you up and torture you
did he say senora what does strange mean
the fact that the future can run amok
across the seven nations like they do
is entirely because of the eleven
we need to act quickly before she gets
wind of what's going on
never heard of what are you lot doing
here
what and just
think you can look at the will of schnez
dropper the more
the merrier over here
oh
he says the key is in here shall we try
another room
[Music]
oh
[Music]
time to move on to another room
[Music]
time to move on to another room there's
one room left that we haven't tried
surely the key must be in there
i am a proud
um
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
where did you write scurry out from
[Music]
this kind of interference in our affairs
so i'll be the one to take care of you
save her the trouble of having to deal
with you herself
prepare yourself
leaving so prepare to be blown away
ah
no escape
prepare yourself
come a little closer
[Music]
no escape
[Music]
can't run from dead
finally the liar is back in safe hands
where did that guy
senora is going to end you this big talk
for a gun